Jordan,
thank you so much for giving us some
time.
Again.
I'm in Sydney.
You're in Kentucky.
Yes,
I am.
I'm,
I'm there as part of my 12 rules for
life tour,
which is I think expanding to hit about
maybe 80 cities,
something like that.
Goodness.
Well that was very keen to have a follow
up chat after the conversation that you
and I had together when you're in
Sydney.
Uh,
and in particular to frame that for
people who might be listening to this
conversation at that time,
I had not seen you in front of a live
audience the evening of that
conversation.
After that conversation,
I had that opportunity at chatswood one
of the seven talks that you gave in
Australia put together by Sam Mcclellan
from a,
from a Melbourne,
every one of them or sell out.
I'll have to say,
I don't know whether the biggest issue
for me is what I learned by watching
that.
All the questions that arise out of it.
But the first thing I'd say is I was
concerned at the time that you and I had
had a very long conversation that might
be too long for people when we put it on
the website and you said,
no,
John won't be young people especially
are hungry for content.
Put it all up there.
They will listen to it.
You're absolutely right.
Young people looking for content.
It is absolutely amazing.
Yeah.
So well,
I mean some of the big youtube stars
like Joe Rogan,
they're constantly putting out three
hour podcasts and people listened to all
of them.
Long haul truckers listen to them and
guys driving forklifts and and young
people and couples.
And there's a massive hunger for real
for Ed,
for high quality educational material.
It shouldn't be underestimated.
And I mean one of the things that seems
to be the case with these people on
Youtube that are making a splash,
let's say in this alternate media
format,
is that they fully have full respect for
the intelligence of their audience and
they don't pull any punches in terms of
content or lakes.
Yeah,
well that's where the come back to that.
But as I say,
you know,
it's just extraordinary.
I pull up a field station out in the
country town near where I live,
uh,
and somebody gets out of the car next to
me,
a follow of about 35,
I suppose,
and he looks at me and he just says
straight up before he even says hello,
he said,
I've just been listening to you and
Jordan Peterson having a conversation.
And everywhere I go now that's what
people say.
So thank you for the opportunity.
You made the comment there,
the for every,
uh,
youtube visit,
they'd be up to 11 podcasts.
I think that's what you said.
Well,
the podcast market is absolutely
exploding and you're actually seeding,
seeding this start to effect book
publishing because audio books have
become extraordinarily popular and
people are discovering that they can use
their phone time when they're commuting
or,
or exercising or walking or doing
dishes,
whatever,
to engage themselves in high quality.
Well,
high quality educational material,
books and podcasts.
And so that's a real revolution it.
And it really is a revolution.
People young people to you,
not instead of listening to music,
which is really something because
music's been a predominant cultural
force for a very long time,
so it's an.
It's an amazing technological revolution
and I really appreciated our
conversation by the way.
I think we had a great conversation.
I enjoyed it immensely and it seems to
me that this is a sort of modern version
and the.
I think this is terrific,
if I'm understanding correctly,
are they all da da way.
People who perhaps had another great
formal education had access to good
quality literature and so forth put
together by whether it was penguin or a.
What was it?
Every man's book,
so every,
every diet books,
whatever they were called.
Even reader's digest to Mike.
That education,
that learning the classics and so forth,
available widely and now this is a
modern version of it perhaps.
Well,
and I think what's happening,
it's a main street.
They underestimate the,
the moral quality of their viewers.
They underestimate their intelligence.
They underestimate their persistence and
they've also become quite manipulative
in their use of editing and message
massaging,
spin really.
And the other thing that's really good
about these sorts of conversations is
that what you see is what you get.
They're bare bones,
they're not high tech.
Well they are,
and their highest tech in some sense,
but not on the production end or the
editing end.
So people can trust them and they're
genuine conversations.
They're not designed to craft a message
or anything like that.
They're not manipulative.
And,
and that's a big deal in youtube.
Youtube particularly doesn't respond
well to manipulation as far as I can
tell.
Well,
uh,
Andrea,
that conversations are enormously.
I've been stunned by the response.
Uh,
it's gone very,
very widely as you know,
uh,
both on your site and Oman.
Um,
but to come back to that die later that
day,
you got one of the talks of the,
one of the seven that you gave in
Australia chatswood.
And uh,
I was very kindly allowed to compare it
for.
And one thing that 19 years in public
life taught me is to have a bit of a
look at your audience and summarize
them.
A,
it was a pretty amazing experience.
The first thing had happened was that
you worked on for,
you said a word,
you'd got a standing ovation.
That's something unheard of in this
country,
but they did a 90 minutes top.
I gave you another standing ovation.
Uh,
you left,
came for a few minutes,
came back on,
took 30 minutes of questions,
and again,
they responded in the same way.
Let me just say a couple of things about
that audience.
I was,
firstly,
I've got to say pretty heavily impacted
as I looked out there and recognized
that there was an enormous hunger to
hear what you had to say.
Even though you mentioned it was perhaps
best described as tough love.
You weren't ginger,
ring them up with a soft story.
You were really pushing you or really
challenging them.
The second thing that struck me is that
I've said many times since I reckon 50
percent of the people in that room at
night where young Australian men under
the age of probably 35.
Uh,
the third thing that struck me was that,
that was a,
it was a cross section.
Uh,
I would say many of them were university
students,
but all university graduates,
but many,
many will not.
And the fourth thing that,
it just goes back to something you said
a moment ago,
they knew what you were signing and
you're a clinical psychologist in a
highly educated person to suggest that
they didn't understand would be very
patronizing.
They ain't got what you're on about.
Oh,
definitely.
There's,
there's no doubt about that.
I mean,
there are,
those lectures aren't interesting unless
you understand them and there's just no
doubt that that's happening.
You know,
I think one of the mistakes that
psychologists have made,
especially the more popular ones over
the last three or four decades,
is to try to convince people that
they're okay the way they are.
It's like the self esteem movement,
you know,
you should love yourself the way you
are.
You should feel good about yourself the
way you are.
And that's actually not a very
optimistic message for people because
people are generally sensible enough to
not be particularly satisfied with the
way that they are.
They want to be who they could be.
They want to have something noble Tane
map and,
and so I,
I make that case for very strong that
you should more,
um,
what aligned and on board with who you
can be then with who you are and who you
can be.
Isn't the person who has endless rights
or,
or as the member of a privileged or
underprivileged group,
it should be who you should be,
should be an individual who's willing to
take on full responsibility for the,
for the catastrophe of existence.
And for the malevolence that's part of
it.
And See,
I think people are responding to that,
first of all because everyone who has
any sense knows that life is a tragic
business and that everyone is
susceptible to be trail and malevolence
on their own part.
And,
and as a consequence of the actions of
others.
That's our existential predicament.
And I think people also know in a very
deep sense that the to that isn't
security or safety.
Um,
and it's not envy or bitterness.
It's the willingness to try to work,
to make the world a better place,
to start with yourself,
take responsibility for yourself.
And then to take responsibility for your
family and then to take responsibility
for your community.
And everyone knows that the people they
admire are exactly the people that do
that.
And we also all know that that's what
gets you out of bed on a rough morning.
It's that you've got something important
and vital to do and it's not an easy
thing.
It isn't necessarily even something that
makes you happy.
It's something that's meaningful and
necessary to fight back against the
tragedy and the malevolence of the
world.
And people know that deeply.
It's deeply rooted inside their souls,
I would say.
And a call to that is very meaningful
for people,
including me.
You know,
I include myself in my audience.
It's not like I'm lecturing to them
precisely.
I'm having a conversation with them
about how we can step the world right
and we are setting it right.
Things are getting better very rapidly
around the world and we can really push
that forward in the decades to come if
we,
if we made a conscious effort.
And so I think this is a very exciting
message for people.
One of the things that are outside about
Australians is I got the world's best
bulldust detectors by recognize
authenticity,
authenticity very quickly.
And if you're not authentic,
they won't listen.
So I think in part they were responding.
If I can pay you a compliment by the
fact that you were talking about you,
you were talking about us,
you,
uh,
addressing where we are all together as
human beings and in why it was designed
you assigning to get to the good news.
You've actually got to go through what
might be called the valley of death.
You've got to face yourself.
You've got to be realistic about
yourself in the world that you live in.
And I,
all those young people.
It was almost as though they were saying
was sick to death of a therapy culture.
A culture that offers a sort of.
It's a relief to everyone.
There's a,
there's a dictum that Carl young derived
from the great outcome of sex Mr Colinas
inventory,
and it means what you most want will be
found where you least want to look,
what you most need will be found where
you least want to look.
And that people know that know everyone
knows that they are tired of naive
optimism,
let's say,
and not optimism.
Optimism doesn't have to be naive and
they know perfectly well that the way to
set themselves right is to take careful
stock of themselves and to pay very
careful attention to the errors that
they know they're making and to and to
grow up and to mature and to and to
adopt the responsibilities of a
forthright citizen.
And I think people are sick to death of
too much discussion of rights and and
too much discussion of self esteem and
all that.
All that.
All that discussion that goes along with
what everyone owes you.
It's like it's just not helpful to
people because it isn't your rights that
give you meaning in life and you need a
meaning to set against the tragedy and
everyone knows that.
The way that you find that meaning is by
adopting responsibility.
Obviously for yourself.
You've got to take care of yourself,
your family.
I mean you want to be a good person to
your parents.
You want to be a good person to your
siblings and your children.
Clearly and you have to bear some
responsibility for your community and if
you're really firing on all cylinders,
you do all those things at the same
time.
You know,
and and I do believe,
and I tell people,
I do believe that the world,
if the tragic and malevolent place in
many,
many ways,
but that the way forward through that is
is to do everything you can to put
yourself on the side of what's good and
to aim high and that that's where you
get the dignity that enables you to to
bear life without becoming corrupt and
everyone knows this is true.
Who's gonna?
Argue with that?
Having found yourself on having of your
like and being realistic about yourself
on recognizing we were talking about
this last time.
A dividing line between good and evil is
not between black and white or whatever.
A captor and Jayla.
I'm an old man and woman at somewhere
across every human heart.
Having recognized that and you can then
go on and help build a stronger,
fairer and more just more humane society
rather than what seems to be the way
people approach it at the moment and
say,
uh,
that somehow rather you society can fix
your problems.
Yes.
Well that's it and I mean for young
people in particular at skidsteer,
actually a very depressing message for
young people to hear that it's time for
them to get involved in political
activism because any young person who
has any sense knows perfectly well and
if they're,
especially if they're 18 or so,
19 years old,
is they don't know a damn thing.
You know,
they haven't started a business.
They haven't started a family.
They don't have a permanent
relationship.
They're not educated.
They don't have any experience.
And for someone to come and say,
well,
you're in a position to change the world
is nothing but a way of,
of disenchanting them with adult wisdom.
It's like you're not ready to change the
world.
You've got a lot to learn,
but you can learn it.
And in learning it,
you will become much more powerful and
much more charismatic and much more
articulate and much more wise and
sensible,
and that's the way forward to to being
much more than you are.
And young people.
Of course,
when you're 18 and you have 60 years of
life ahead of you,
what you want to hear above all else is
that there's way more of you yet to come
because what else are you going with
those 60 years?
So it's,
it's a message.
It's a hard message because it says,
well,
you're not everything you could be,
but it's a deeply optimistic message
because it's because the idea is that
you could be way more than you are
incomparably more than you are.
And I do believe that.
And what's so fun about this is that
people keep telling me that,
keep people keep telling me that it's
true.
You know,
I have people,
endless people.
I've got one kid come up to me the other
day.
It was so fun.
He said,
a year and a half ago,
I had just got out of jail and I was
homeless.
And he said,
I started listening to your lectures and
I just,
I got married this year,
I have a vagina and I just bought my
apartment.
It's like,
wow man,
good work,
you know,
you did that in a year and a half and
I was in la the other about a month ago
and you know,
this was in a rough part of La,
downtown La near the Apollo theater.
And I'd given a talk there.
My wife and I were walking down the
street and this car pulled up and this
kid hopped out and he was about 19 or so
good luck and Hispanic kid ran over and
asked me if I was Dr Peterson.
I said yes.
And he was all excited.
He said it'd been watching my videos for
about a year and a half and they really
helped him straighten out his life.
He was just smiling the way.
He said,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Then he ran back to his car and he came
back out with his dad and his dad was
standing there,
you know,
and they have their arms around each
other and they were just grinning like
mad and the kid said,
look,
I've really put my relationship together
with my father and were really on board
with this together and they were just
like so happy you couldn't believe it.
And that just happens over and over.
Like it happens I would say four or five
times a day in restaurants or in
airports through while you've been
experiencing that to some degree in
Australia you said,
and it's,
it's so good.
And the mainstream media that's been
covering what I've been doing,
you know,
they just missed this completely because
everything.
It seems like everything that
constitutes news in our society has to
be political and group oriented.
This isn't political and it's not group
oriented.
What I'm trying to do as a good clinical
psychologist and perhaps a good educator
and I mean good striving to be good in
the moral sense is to help people
develop as individuals and they are and
it's really working.
And it's a thrill to be on this tour
because that's all I hear and now no one
talks to me about the political issues
or very,
very rarely,
and it's all because I also think that
the battle against collective is to,
let's say,
the battle against identity politics
isn't to be had in the political realm.
And maybe that's a secondary issue.
What the way that you,
that you fight for the sovereignty of
the individual is by getting your act
together and,
and right locally,
right where you are,
and starting to take advantage of
everything that you have in front of
you.
And,
and then you do no harm that way.
All you do is make yourself less bad.
Who,
what's the harm in that?
That's a good thing
to some extent.
I think the battle here is almost one of
statism or collectivism versus
individual liberty,
who's going to shape who?
So you've got the whole,
the sort of push from the lift identity,
politics,
victimhood policies,
uh,
approaches and what have you.
We owe these people what have you.
So the state has control and shapes
individuals and helps them forward.
On the other hand,
you have the different view that says,
now the state should be shaped by the
people who make up the state.
You know,
Australia is a sum total of individuals
who are Australian and they ought to be
shaping the public square,
not having the public square of your
local,
the public sector,
shaping them.
The whole argument is about what?
What?
What's the primary unit of analysis?
That's everything.
What's the primary unit of analysis and
in the West,
the primary unit of the analysis has
been the logos and that something like
divine individual consciousness and it's
on that ground that we developed our
idea of individual sovereignty and
citizenship and you know,
we don't talk about a citizen is someone
who adopts the responsibilities of an
ethical being.
That's a citizen.
We don't talk about that even in schools
and tell people that look,
the meaning in your life is going to be
found.
It's going to be proportionate to the
degree that you take responsibility for
positively shaping your experience and
the experience of the people around you.
And this isn't like be good in some in
some week,
be inoffensive and harmless sense.
It's not that at all.
It's like get your spine straight,
get your aggression integrated,
pick a heavy goal,
like a heavy high goal,
something you can barely tolerate
lifting and struggled along with it.
And that's where you'll find yourself
respect and people know that it's,
it's fun to watch the working class guys
respond to this too,
you know,
because they know this.
Most of those guys worked like mad,
you know,
and they know that there's no ability in
that and,
and there is and so it's well and people
also say,
well that they're happy to come to my
lectures or even read the book because
I'm helping them find words to express
things that they already knew to be
true.
And those things that they know to be
true are the bedrock axioms of our
culture.
And one of the things we got right in
the West was the idea of the sovereign
responsible individual,
not the person with rights and certainly
not the person with rights granted to
them by the state.
That's not part of the English common
law tradition.
You're the locus of rights,
but,
but only in some sense because you're
the locus of ultimate responsibility.
I guess part of what I've been trying to
tell people is that there's no
difference between meaning and
responsibility.
They're the same thing.
Yeah,
no,
I understand what you're saying.
Now.
As I looked at that audience,
I thought to myself,
we're doing a lot of talking about the
first world war in this country.
60,000
Australians died out of a very small
population in that horrendous event and
we celebrate the bribery those young and
Zach's,
we call them who went off to college and
then to the western front and were
involved in some of the critical battles
of the first world war every year.
Australians turnout and extraordinary
numbers and more and more young
Australians turnout to have you like pay
tribute to the courage.
And as I looked out across a wide
audience,
I thought,
there's a lot of people here that I've
willingly,
oh,
I would choose to be with in the
trenches.
They are essentially people who want to
be.
To use the word you did just a moment
ago,
noble to the best of their ability,
but I live in a culture somehow that
says,
no,
that's all nonsense.
That's not where you want to go.
And it seemed to me that they'd deeply
resenting and deeply keen to reject
that approach.
Here's,
here's what it is.
So there's this idea that,
um,
it's pushed very hard in the
universities by the postmodern,
Neo Marxists types and before anybody
objects I know perfectly well that
technically speaking,
postmodernism in Neo Marxists,
neo Marxism aren't commensurate,
but it doesn't stop people from,
from joining them together.
It theologically.
But in any case,
the idea is that the West is
fundamentally an oppressive patriarchy,
which it isn't.
It's partly an oppressive society
because every society is partly
oppressive and flawed,
but fundamentally the West is not an
oppressive patriarchy.
And,
but if you buy that line,
then the next thing that comes along is
that anything you do that contributes to
that patriarchy is also oppressive.
Tyrannical.
And so that's extraordinarily
demoralizing for people who are trying
to make their way in the world because
they're trying to hoist the
responsibilities up on their shoulders
and become competent,
contributing adults,
and they're criticized to death for
being oppressive tyrants.
And so there's a conflation of
competence with tyranny and you can't do
anything to anyone that's more
demoralizing,
not you know,
then that Nisha said,
if you want to punish someone,
punish them for their virtues.
And so they're tired of that.
It's so demoralizing.
You don't like it appeals to the part of
each man,
let's say an each woman for that matter
who will wants to avoid responsibility
because you can rationalize it and say,
well,
I'm not going to take responsibility
because that just makes me a tyrant and
an an agent of the patriarchy.
But that's a.
That sort of thing leads people down a
path.
And I've seen that my friends and in my
clinical practice it.
So instead we say,
look like our culture has problems.
Every culture does and it needs
everyone.
Everyone has to be awake so that we
don't slip at every level of our social
being into something like a blind
authoritarianism,
but the way that that happens is by
waking up and taking responsibility once
again for for yourself and your family
and your community and that that and
that's noble,
which is a word you never hear.
It's like a human being has to be a
noble creature to withstand the tragedy
of existence without becoming corrupt
and so and and that,
that,
that coal is to the best in people
and Jordan,
just a.
We should wrap up on that part of it
that evening night,
but there was one other thing when we
kind of questions on.
There will full marks in the room.
They land up 20 deep at eight.
We got to seven.
I think the seventh question was from a
lady who asked a very intelligent
question about what parents bring to
their children and and in particular
were they things that mothers bought to
their children that women do best and
other things that fathers bring to their
children that are best.
You gave a very rousing answer.
The issue of fathering,
and as I say,
there were a lot of men there,
I gather that your audience is the
demographics of broadened out now,
but that was a very young man centric
group.
Uh,
and you hammered the importance as I
heard it.
I'll fathering.
Well,
the,
the empirical literature on this is
absolutely clear.
I mean,
you know,
we have this idea that's being pushed
forward that all families are equal.
So like there's a,
there's a grain of truth in that in that
people who are struggling,
uh,
mightily to raise their children
properly are,
are worthy of respect whether they are
single or in couples,
but the empirical literature is
absolutely clear that that stable,
intact father families with fathers,
they're produced children who do way
better on almost every possible measure
and even more than that,
that in communities where fathers tend
to be at home or when you know,
as part of the stable family,
the communities themselves do better.
Even those kids that don't have fathers
at home.
So the role of father there is
unbelievably important.
Then the question is what particular
role does a father plan?
I just had a good conversation with
Warren Farrell about that and part of,
part of my research should indicated
that men are particularly useful in
initiating rough and tumble play and
play with their children in general and
feral extended that by noting that men
could use the opportunity to play as a
reward for delaying gratification among
their children.
That's a really big deal because one of
the things you have to do to help people
matures,
to teach them to delay gratification and
to sustain attention and it looks like
men that the pleasure that children get
in playing with their fathers rough and
tumble play,
but other forms of play as well.
The primary reward that can be used to
help children learn to make the proper
sacrifices and regulate their impulses
over the longterm.
So,
so,
you know,
and I think fathers now of course
mothers can do this too,
but I think fathers,
um,
are because mothers are generally
charged with the fundamental care of
infants.
There's a tension between that and
encouraging children to step forward out
into the world as,
as courageous beings.
And you know,
mothers are very,
very attached to their infants and their
infants are very fragile and so often
hard for them to make the transition
from primary security provider and
caregiver too forthright,
encourager of adventure.
And that's certainly something that
fathers can do,
is it's better to construe life as an
adventure rather than as an enterprise
that's there to make you feel secure or
happy.
It's a great adventure and a dangerous
one at that because everyone's life is
at stake in this adventure,
you know,
were unbelievably tough creatures if we,
if we put ourselves out fully.
Okay.
Now you said something very interesting
and very important than my view.
You talked about empirical evidence in
relation to the importance of fathering
empirical evidence,
reason evidenced based decision making
come thoughtful deliberation rather than
emotion and other words.
The difference between thinking and
feeling seems to me to be incredibly
important.
We should follow the facts the way they
take us,
but we're confronted.
Bought seems to be.
You mentioned and you said they're not
related,
but we taught them together a sort of a
cultural Marxism and postmodernism.
It seems to me the cultural Marxist will
deliberately distort the truth because
of their agendas or hide the truth
because of their agendas,
the postmodernists to fallen into this
trap of if you like,
moral relativity,
so what's good for you is true for you
and what's good familiar is true for me.
Even if they really painting black is
white and white is black.
Isn't that a problem?
It's worse than that in some sense
because it's not even.
What's true for you is true for you and
what's true for me is true for me.
It's why it's true for your group is
only good for your group and what's true
for my group is only good for my group,
and so that sets this off often in group
conflict and in tribal sort of way.
You know the,
the,
the real radical types who are swallowed
up by this ideology believe that science
itself is nothing but a euro centric
patriarchal construct.
I mean,
they dispense completely with the fact
that scientific discovery has given us
this incredible technological power
that's lifted the entire world out of
abject poverty in a period of about a
hundred and 50 years for that for them,
for some reason that doesn't constitute
evidence.
And so when you bring up evidence that
there's hand waving because the people
who dispute this sort of thing rarely
know the details of the literature,
they just write it off and say,
well,
that whole scientific enterprise,
that's just part of the way that
eurocentric males dominate and destroy
the planet.
It's all power games for these people.
There's no,
there's no reality at the bottom of it
outside of the power gate.
And so that's uh,
well that,
that to me,
that,
that's a,
that's a viewpoint that leads inevitably
to tribal conflict.
That's all.
That's what it does.
Now you might be able to help me.
I think it was George Orwell who made a
reference to an ID being so utterly
stupid that only a member of the
intelligentsia could believe it.
No sensible person in the street would
accept it for a moment.
There was a bit of there that night.
I would have thought you actually
might've comment quite a a.
I thought a very astute remark that
about something that an absolutely
obvious and then you follow finished it
by saying you would have thought someone
in a university somewhere might've
noticed now always been an academic at
any university in Australia.
I would have realized that I needed to
wake up to myself because the audience
lifted the roof off the place with their
applause.
They are highly skeptical about what is
happening now in our educational
institutions.
There is no other way to read that
audience of a thousand decent
Australians.
They are very skeptical about the value
for money we're getting now out of our
tertiary education sector.
Yeah,
well it's the whole education sector to
I would say increasingly from
kindergarten all the way through
university.
Yeah.
I think that I'm embarrassed,
increasingly embarrassed to be a member
of the academy because of that.
Like I was reading this book today by a
Norwegian called progress.
It's really good book.
I would highly recommend it.
Very straightforward and all it is is a
compendium of empirical facts about how
much better the world has been getting
for the last hundred and 50 years and
just every possible way,
300,000
people a week or being hooked to the
Electrical Power Grid,
right?
We,
we've reduced,
we've almost eliminated.
I'm starvation throughout the world
except for political reasons and
starvation was a big problem in places
like Sweden and Italy less than 100
years ago.
Orland
people are.
People have access to fresh water and
the fastest growing economies in the
world are in Subsaharan Africa and we're
just making progress.
Progress on every possible front and
everything that people learn in the
education system seems to be associated
with the idea that human beings are a
cancerous growth on the planet,
that we're going to hell in a handbasket
and that we're going to burn ourselves
out in the next 50 years and dye and
it'll be our fault too.
And you know,
it's just not the case.
It's simply not the case.
I mean,
we have problems in front of us,
but there's a deep anti human ethos that
permeates that.
And you know,
maybe it's still a hangover from our
pessimism from the Cold War,
you know,
because everyone was truly terrified for
about five decades that we were going to
put everything to the torch,
you know,
and maybe we still haven't really
recovered from that and it's not
surprising because it was brutal.
But reading this book on progress just
made me think again how badly we're
educated because people just don't know
how much things are getting better and
why free markets are a huge part of it.
Private properties,
a huge part of it.
And that's all associated with the idea
of the sovereign individual.
And so this really works.
I mean,
it's true that Europe got rich first,
but that's only been 100 most at most.
One hundred and 50 years.
Not even that long.
It's really since about 18,
95 and Europe first.
But Man,
China,
there's no one's starving in China.
There's no one's starving in India.
Southeast Asia has enough food and
Subsaharan Africa is growing like mad.
And then we have these,
we have these,
we have our education system that
trumpets,
that,
you know,
we live in a patriarchy that we should
all identify with our tribal groups and
that the right way of Inter,
of viewing history is victimizer group
against victim group.
So like it's no wonder people are
skeptical of that.
It's,
it's a profoundly anti western ethos.
And the thing is about the west is we
got the sovereign individual,
right?
It's right.
And it's the responsibility part.
That's right.
Not the rights part.
I mean the rights rights are necessary
but,
but only the rights are there so that
you can express your responsibility.
That's what,
that's the whole point.
Okay,
well let's come to this issue of our own
almost loading now.
Have our own beliefs and values.
I'm here in Australia now.
We're having a,
an extraordinary to going on a very
wealthy and a lockable on us soil
philanthropists.
Cold Pole Ramsay who was very active in
the hill center,
left a very large amount of money to me,
might available to set up a,
an academy for the study of Western
civilization.
And he wanted it to be done in one of
our major universities.
Now,
one of our most acclaimed universities
ended into deep negotiations.
Uh,
then,
uh,
the education union got involved and
said,
no,
this is going to be terrible.
It will be all about European audience
of European supremacy.
So that same university has sent us for
Islamic studies for indigenous studies.
They are not particularly autonomous in
the sense that,
uh,
the university.
Oh,
sorry,
they're not particularly controlled.
It seems by the university they do
pretty much their own thing,
but all now you can't have a center for
the study of Western civilization.
It will fill us up with all sorts of
racist ideas,
a supremacist ideas.
This is really worrying if we can
understand our own past.
In fact,
there's a very wise,
I Asian said here the other day,
if you wanted them to understand,
I Asian cultures understand you for your
own first.
Well,
it means to me it's just,
first of all,
you know,
in some sense I'm less worried about
what's happening with the universities
than I was because I think that they're
going to destroy themselves completely.
If they continue the way they are and
that all that's going to happen is that
people will take the genuine value in
the wisdom of the past and presented an
alternative forms.
We'll just steal it out from underneath
the universities.
I would say to the philanthropist,
if the universities don't want the
money,
then they should set up an institute on
their own.
That my very well be a good course.
You can go directly to the people now,
you know,
like for now.
So for example,
for me,
if I want a lecture now,
I can lecture on anything I want,
whenever I want,
with no bureaucratic restrictions and I
have an audience of people who are only
listening because they want to listen.
That's where the university is.
The university is where there's an
audience of people who are only
listening because they want to be
educated.
That is the university.
The buildings are irrelevant.
Let's,
let's build on that from Abbott because
what's in this debate unfold in
Australia were listening to academic
signing on.
I know we've got to preserve our
academic integrity.
Uh,
and we've,
we're here to protect our policies of
diversity and inclusiveness,
uh,
and all of those sorts of things.
And somebody topic pointed out actually
we thought they were there to teach our
young people how to think for themselves
primarily
that isn't what they're there for
because that's predicated on the idea
that there are sovereign individuals and
that they can actually think for
themselves as individuals.
The whole idea here is that you're not
an individual,
you're the member of a group.
That's it.
And they're serious about this.
This isn't a trivial objection,
it's a fundamental objection.
But I would also say,
look,
there's a new testament statement,
don't cast pearls before swine.
And you know,
that usually has to do with words,
right?
Don't waste words of wisdom and those
who will not here,
but you can also just look at it
literally.
If you have pearls and you're trying to
give them to someone and they won't take
them,
then go find someone else to give the
pearls to.
If you're trying to give money to a
university to do something great and
they won't take it,
it's obvious that they don't want to do
anything great,
so don't give them the money.
It's the wrong people.
Okay,
well,
let's tease this out a little bit more
wisdom.
You've mentioned the difference between
if you like knowledge and accumulated
cleverness and what have you,
and wisdom.
Surely there's a difference because to
go back again to Chatswood,
I would say a good chunk of the people
there were not university educated,
but they were smart and I would say like
odd side more.
They will wise.
They were striving for wisdom and that's
where wisdom is.
Wisdom is in the striving for wisdom and
wisdom is really act.
Wisdom isn't a collection of facts.
Wisdom is knowledge of how to conduct
yourself in the world.
So it's a.
it's an action.
It's an existential issue.
It's,
it's,
it's truth.
As revealed in action.
That's wisdom.
Where's the most,
how understands consequences?
Well,
it's in.
It's sophisticated in its understanding
of consequences because you think,
well,
what are the consequences?
And the answer is,
well,
there's the consequences for you now and
for you next week and next month and
five years from now,
so the consequences are you and future
you,
so that's an iterated game,
but the consequences are also for your
family now and in the future and for
your community now and in the future.
And wisdom is the ability to consider
all of those consequences as part of
your,
as part of what guides your vision and
your and your and your operations in the
world.
And that's character.
And then nobility of character is to
take all of those things into account.
Simultaneously.
As I watched the debate,
I thought it to some extent,
one of the problems you've got here see
us Louis.
Mater of a pointed out,
is pride,
pride,
getting in the way of people having
sufficient humility to recognize that
the nonsense say paddling is simply
unconvincing in terms of what you might
call the pub test.
What would pass the pub test out there
where people have common sense and can
see when people are being real and when
they're not being real?
Well,
it's easy to dispense with that.
You just develop sufficient contempt for
the common person and then you don't
have to worry about what they think and
that's and that's when you confuse being
smart with being wise and they're not
the same thing.
I don't think there's any relationship
between them.
In fact,
I mean intelligence is a great gift,
but it can go terribly wrong and it can
certainly turned into a kind of
intellectual arrogance,
that's for sure.
That blinds you to do your own ignorance
and humility is the antidote to that and
the,
the humility of the element of humility
there that's necessary is to understand
that what you don't know is more
important than what you know.
And so if you're an India log,
you,
you dispense with all that because you
already know everything.
I was gonna say,
I was reminded of that front I chatswood
has,
as you've probably gathered,
it had a big impact on man.
It was a powerful reminder to me that
familiar.
It seems very important to recognize
that there's a sense in which the more
you learn,
the more you realize you don't know him
very much and there's a lot more to
learn.
Yeah.
Well,
in north,
you know,
being with an audience can help with
that too because if you're,
if you're talking to an audience,
you can check to see if your message is
being received.
You know,
when you might say,
well these people just can't understand
what I have to say.
It's like,
well yeah,
they probably can if you,
if you formulated it carefully and you
actually talked to them.
Individual individual,
which is what I try to do in my
lectures.
Like I'm not talking to the mob,
I'm not talking to the group.
I never talked to the group when I'm
lecturing.
I always pick people in the audience and
speak right to them and they reflect the
audit.
You know,
they reflect the entire group but they
only reflect it because the group is
made up of individuals like them.
So let's just go back to something you
said earlier that it struck me as very
interesting,
and that is that young people don't want
to be involved in political activism.
I want to get himself sorted out first.
Many of those young people,
uh,
I think one of behave nobly and help
build a better society,
a strongest civic square,
if I can put it that way and good on
them.
That's terrific.
That's important.
They're very disillusioned with politics
and yet we have to govern our country.
We have to make certain that the rules
are set,
if you like,
uh,
and that we maximize everybody's
opportunities to live in freedom and
insecurity when young people have,
if you like,
grounded themselves and feel ready to
act,
nobody in the public square,
what should they do?
How can they make a difference?
They want to make a difference.
How do I go about it?
Oh,
more more power to them I think.
But I think you know,
they,
they start by realizing they don't know
anything and by starting to learn and if
they learn and work and disciplined
themselves,
the opportunities to expand will come
naturally because people will notice
them.
Like,
look,
if you with competent people,
hyper competent people,
one of the things you learn is that
hyper competent people are always
looking for young people to mentor.
Yeah,
starving and hoping that someone will
come along who,
who has a lot of potential and then what
they'll do is offer them a and
opportunity.
I keep my eye out at the university and
in my private work as well all the time
for young people who've got something to
contribute,
to say,
oh,
you look like you're sharp.
That's find out,
here's a task.
Why don't you go try this?
Then they come back and knock it out of
the park and you think,
oh,
that's good because I got 20 more things
here that need doing that I can't do.
I've got more opportunities that I know
what to do with.
Here's another one.
And so the thing is is that if you
develop your confidence and you
discipline yourself and you start to
make that manifest in any hierarchy
that's even vaguely competent,
you'll have more opportunities come your
way,
then you'll know what to do with it.
It all happened organically.
So and it,
it,
it is the way of the world,
and well,
if that isn't happening in the
organization that you're working with
and you're working diligently and you
have your art together,
then it's time to find a different
organization.
But generally speaking,
most organizations aren't that corrupt.
Some are
interesting,
I'd say that Australia is.
We worship youth culture and why,
but one of the things I've noticed about
youth is that overwhelmingly,
if I have the opportunity to tap into
the wisdom of an older person to be
mentored,
they go looking for it.
They're very keen for it.
Well,
it's part of the part of the human
proclivity to admire and imitate.
You know what I mean?
One of the things that draws us forward,
we don't only learn by facts,
in fact,
we hardly learned by facts and all.
We learn by stories.
And we learn by invitation and we,
they imitate those we admire and we
admire those who are competent.
And so if you find someone who knows
what you don't and can operate
effectively in the world in a manner
that you would like to,
but town,
then you're going to admire them.
And if you admire them,
you're going to open the door to have
them mentor you.
And I mean,
that's,
that's really fundamental to human
cognition and human psychological
development.
It's the catalyst for human development
because we're deeply imitative.
It's,
it's the thing that distinguishes us
from other creatures,
perhaps even more than even more
fundamentally than language use.
If I watch you,
if you know how to do something and I
watch you do it,
I can learn to do it without having to
go through all the pain that you had to
go through to learn it.
It's such a gift.
That's why history is so important.
Our personal history,
uh,
if you locked out family history.
I was thinking the other day that my
grandfather made a mistake with my
father on the farm that I'm determined
because I can learn from that,
not to repeat with my own son on the
farm.
Um,
and then there's of course the broader
cultural history,
which is why I believe,
and I think you're,
when you're not share this view,
we to learn from our history,
we ought to learn from the horrors of
collectivism in Soviet Russia.
We ought to be honest about it.
We should teach our young people at the
same time,
as we're honest about the watson,
our own cultural history,
but we're also honest about the
nobility.
For example,
the mighty pushed to abolish slavery.
Surely the greatest human rights
movement of all time.
We ought to know about it.
It's noble.
It was led by noble people who've
struggled against extraordinary odds for
a long time.
Yes,
exactly.
And in slavery was a human universal.
So it's an,
it's an amazing,
miraculous attainment.
It's miraculous attainment.
Absolutely.
And you know,
what we're supposed to be doing in new
universities is separating the wheat
from the chaff,
not dispensing with everything.
As if it's because we don't want to put
in the effort to discriminate and so
it's easier.
Well,
it's just all corrupt.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
People aren't starving to death anymore
and societies are increasingly free and
children are dying in the massive
numbers that they want to start in and
people are.
People's life expectancy has doubled.
Like things are going pretty well.
Don't mock it up and we need to figure
out why and we need to take stock of the
things that we didn't pass that were
wrong obviously,
but that doesn't mean that everything
everyone did in the past was wronged.
That stuff.
That's not thinking,
that's just,
that's just reflexive resentment
masquerading as intellectual
superiority.
There's nothing about it.
That's good.
Well,
you've been incredibly generous with
your time.
Can we wrap up,
let's just think through what would we
say in terms of people looking for
solutions,
uh,
in academia and the media in politics.
How do we,
if you like,
stop the movement to reclaim what you
called evidence based empirical decision
evidenced in decision making.
In other words,
learn to think again and stop being so,
so emotional.
There's a place for emotion,
but there's a place for thinking.
I think.
Well,
I mean if you're a university student,
the first thing you want to note is that
you're there to learn,
to think and to write and to read and to
speak.
That's what you're there to do and the
reason you're there to do that is
because that makes you incredibly
competent because you're going to have
to communicate with people for the rest
of your life and if your communication
that has the depth and clarity,
then you can see your way forward and
you can bring other people aboard and
you can do great things and so it's
super.
It's super useful to get a real liberal
arts education because it can make you
into a great communicator and thinker.
If you're going to university,
read the great books and you'll continue
confined professors who will teach you
that,
but that's what you're there to do.
You're there to spend four years
immersing yourself in the imitation of
the greatest people that our culture has
produced,
and if you think,
well,
there were no great people,
well then you might as well not through
the university because university is the
storehouse of the thoughts of great
people.
Then if you dispense with the whole
notion,
notion of great,
then maybe you're there to become a
political activist,
but that's not university.
That's something else that's like an
ideological cult and maybe that's what
you want.
And,
and,
and I mean you'll,
you'll pay the price for that one way or
the other,
but even as a university student,
you have to take on the burden of
educating yourself to a large degree,
but you have to decide that that's what
you want and that that's what you need
in terms of your own personal life.
I have a program that I developed with
my colleagues called the future
authoring program.
It's a self authoring Dotcom and it
helps people develop a vision for their
life along about six fundamental
dimensions,
family education,
mental and physical health,
career avoidance of temptation like drug
and alcohol use.
Um,
we tried to parse out a use of time,
you productive and meaningful use of
time outside of work.
We tried to parameterize a decent life
and then to guide people through the
process of imagining what their life
could be like if they put it together
properly and you need to develop a
vision for your life and a sense of who
you could be if you were the character
that you could be and,
and thinking through that and
articulating it is actually part of,
it shouldn't be part of a classic
liberal arts education because the whole
point of education apart from the
technical end,
which is important,
is to produce a noble citizen.
That's the point,
not to produce a bloody political
activists.
Well,
let me just,
we should keep in mind though,
because even the chatswood that not a
lot of those people,
most of them are not at university,
so they're not excluded either from in
any way,
shape or form from broadening their
horizon.
It's not like they're not doing
important things like working men,
for example,
working people in general.
I don't care what they're doing.
If they're working at a diner as a
waiter or they're they're.
They're laying bricks or working a
forklift or they're plumbers or these
people are bloody important.
They build the infrastructure and
there's a huge difference between a
craftsman who takes pride in caring what
he's doing and contributes to his family
and the community in that nobility of
work and someone who does a slipshod and
haphazard job.
There's great nobility and genuine work.
So and I believe that you have just as
much power,
let's say,
much as much authority,
as much clout as a forthright and honest
working person as you do as an
intellectual and I mean you can be very
successful as a working person if you.
If you're diligent and honest and
committed and competent and aiming up
because it looked.
I do believe that each person is the
center of the world and you have what
you need right at that center,
and maybe you're not intellectual,
but you're good with your hands and your
practical and solid and people can rely
on you.
It's like,
man,
that's a big deal because then when
their roof blows off in the middle of a
storm,
they can call you up and you're there in
an hour and you put the damn thing back
together and,
and,
and Hooray for.
You said,
all of these things are important.
And so there's great nobility and in
working class work as far as I'm
concerned.
Well,
Jordan,
that's a,
again,
a fascinating conversation from my
perspective and uh,
uh,
it's tremendous to be able to interact
with somebody who,
who cares passionately because that's
what,
that's what they're picking up.
I know it's not about you.
You're actually trying to make a
difference for people.
And you know,
we're seeing this unready disturbed by
the way in which some of these movements
were seeing at the moment of trying to
divide men from women.
And a lot of people getting men are
getting this idea that somehow their
masculinity is toxic.
Uh,
well,
you know,
we don't say that when the brave young
French policeman takes a bullet for a
young woman and her daughter in a French
supermarket,
we celebrate that.
And I actually think that not all,
but the great majority of men want to be
noble.
They know their floors as you said.
They've got to be honest about them.
We all know to be honest,
but they also have a big part of them
maybe like that divine spike.
So to speak,
divine spark that leads them to want to
be responsible.
Noble people.
Yes.
And that's,
that's what women want from men too.
So unless they've been damaged in their
relationship so that they don't trust
men at all.
And then ours are prepared to dispense
with all of them,
which is helpful.
But you know,
men and women need to call to the
nobility in each other and that is what
they both want.
Because you want a stalwart companion by
your side.
You're a man.
You want someone you can trust and who
you can rely on to help guide you and
and and care for you and to care for
your children and all of that,
and to make a life with if you're a
woman,
you want a man that you can rely on and
that's going to help you,
help you deal with the children and with
the excess fragility that you have
because of your pronounced roll and
record production,
and that is what we want and to
denigrate and to split men and women.
A part is,
is too damaged humanity itself because
it's not like we're all men or all
women.
I have sisters and a mother and a white
and women have husbands and sons and
fathers were not separate and I'm just
split us apart on,
on the basis of sex is well,
it's,
it's this pathological as a suicidal
impulse or a murderous impulse or a
genocidal impulses.
None of that's good.
It's not acceptable,
but we're a hell of a lot better off
than we were and things are getting
better and we can do better yet.
That's a way better story.
We'll look forward very much to having
you back on these shores.
Very nice speaking with you again and
thank you very much for the opportunity.
Thanks so much.